-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-All right, here we are,
on Overtime, with the Executive
Vice President of the Center
for International Policy,
Matt Duss,
and the columnist
for Tablet magazine,
Jamie Kirchick.
Here are the things
people want to know.
What explains
Israel's intelligence failure?
Yes, we never got to that.
Why-- I mean-- Wow.
I mean, Netanyahu
was always the security guy.
I mean, people--
"Oh, he's an asshole,
but he's our asshole
and he's going to keep us safe
-and Israel was always--"
-MATT DUSS: Which was always
his main argument.
Yes, and always great
at this kind of stuff
and they have to be, they live
in the roughest neighborhood
in the world.
How did this happen?
Great question.
Well, I think
there was the operational level
where they took out
some sensors, right?
And somehow the Israelis
didn't see that.
But I think there was a larger
strategic picture...
-BILL MAHER: Has to be.
-...where they really did not
think that Hamas would
attempt something like this.
-BILL: Well, they were--
-They thought that
Hamas was something-- Hamas--
They could-- um,
could sort of deal with them
in some way,
but that they would be so--
BILL: They were letting in
guest workers.
-They were letting in
guest workers...
-Right. They were-- They were...
...that Hamas would not be
so irrational or suicidal,
whatever word you want to use,
to actually
perpetrate something.
Yeah. I mean,
I would make two points here.
One is just to understand
the scope of the intelligence
failure here. We're talking
about-- I think it's some 1500
Hamas fighters who were killed
inside Israel,
you had probably
another 500 more
who took the hostages
back into Gaza,
-so we're talking at least
2,000 people.
-BILL: Right.
Um, that's a lot
of people talking.
-BILL: To keep a secret?
-Um, that's a lot--
-Yes, exactly right.
-Right.
The... the idea that
Israeli intelligence
could not figure this out
or know that something
was going on,
but also the second point,
you know, I made reference
to this-- the settlements
to-- to Ben-Gvir.
And Israeli security officials
and others have suggested
that one of the problems
that you had,
a lot of Israeli security
redeployed to the West Bank
to protect settler groups
for the purposes of promoting
settlements attacking
Palestinians and that left
the fence line
relatively undefended,
-which also suggests...
-BILL: Right.
...that Hamas themselves
may have been shocked
at how easy it was
to cross the river.
Also, I may say,
too many Jewish holidays.
-(CHUCKLES)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
What? A lot of...
-I'm gonna let that one slide.
-A lot of the-- (CHUCKLES)
-BILL: A lot of the--
-MATT: As a-- as a Christian...
-A lot of the sol--
-...who got Jewish holidays,
I disagree.
-I disagree.
-A lot of the soldiers were,
like, on leave.
-And you know--
-JAMES KIRCHICK:
That was 50 years
to the day
of the Yom Kippur War.
BILL: You think they would
see that coming.
Yeah, it's like Lou Gehrig
and Lou Gehrig's disease, right?
-How didn't they know?
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-What are the odds? (LAUGHS)
-JAMES: What are the odds?
(CHUCKLES)
(AUDIENCE CHEERS, APPLAUDS)
Okay, uh, well,
Ohio representative,
Jim Jordan... (LAUGHS)
This is-- This is hysterical,
what's going on.
-If it wasn't our Congress,
I'd laugh ha-- harder but...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
You win enough votes
to become speaker,
how does having a speaker
of the house
impact military aid--
JAMES: I'm actually
more concerned, can someone
get this guy a gift certificate
to Brooks Brothers?
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-Yeah, right. Don't you...
I mean seriously.
(AUDIENCE CHEERS, APPLAUDS)
I mean, politicians have always
done the shirt sleeve rolled up,
-but not always...
-JAMES: Yeah.
-Yeah.
-...just when you're trying
to make a point and like,
"I'm a man of the people,"
but sometimes
you have a jacket on.
-JAMES: Yeah.
-Okay.
But now, again,
I may have this recap wrong,
but he was the choice
at the beginning of the week.
Then he--
-MATT: Endorsed by Trump.
-Couldn't get the--
-Because Trump endorsed him.
-Right, right.
Last week I heard it was going
to be Trump himself.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-Because...
Because this is crazy,
in America you don't have to be
-a member of Congress
to be the speaker of the House.
-MATT: That's right. Right.
-Shouldn't you?
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
Isn't-- Is that not a law
we should have?
And then Trump realized
that you have to do stuff.
-BILL: Right.
-It does involve actual work.
-Oh, a lot of work, yes.
-Yeah.
But okay, so then they went
to Steve Scalise.
Steve Scalise, the guy, he was--
you know,
hard right-winger
from Louisiana.
-David Duke without the baggage,
as he described.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-That's in his own words,
said that.
-MATT: In his own words.
Yeah, he said that.
David Duke without the baggage.
I guess that... (LAUGHS)
-It's a little racist--
-The word baggage
is doing a lot
-in that-- in that phrase there.
-(LAUGHS)
Baggage is a little--
That's a little--
-That's when you can't even
get it closed.
-Yeah.
You know, you're just trying
to get the suit...
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDS)
-Uh, yes, but, uh,
and now they're back
as if by the time
this goes on the air
it'll probably be-- be stale
but now we're back
-to Jim Jordan...
-JAMES: Yeah.
...who-- The former gym teacher.
(SNIFFS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-BILL: I call him-- (LAUGHS)
Like-- like Dennis Hastert,
the former wrestling coach.
Wrestling.
Well he was an assistant
wrestling coach, right?
-Yeah, he was. Jim Jordan.
-I call him Jim "Gym" Jordan.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-MATT: Yes.
-(LAUGHS)
-MATT: And, uh, you know,
obviously some very troubling
allegations in his past.
BILL: What?
-Obviously some very troubling
allegations in his past about--
-JAMES: Wait.
-BILL: Yes, well he said--
-You know what they said,
those who can't teach,
-teach Jim.
-(BILL LAUGHS)
-And those who can't...
-(LAUGHS)
-...those who can't teach Jim
become speaker of the House.
-(LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, CHEERING)
So, true. Right.
-MATT: But that's--
-But that's true.
-MATT: That does--
-The other gym teacher
who was the speaker
of the House, Dennis Hastert.
-JAMES: Yeah.
-He was a child molester, right?
-Yeah.
-BILL: Convicted.
Okay, this guy
is not a child molester,
-but he did let it go on.
-That is the allegation, yes.
BILL: That's the allegation.
Okay, we just allegedly--
but he knew about it
but didn't do anything
-to stop it.
-MATT: Right.
Kind of like, you know,
he was, uh, Joe Paterno
to Jerry Sandusky.
-Yep. That's exactly it.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(LAUGHS)
-Sorry. Did that depress you?
Uh... (CHUCKLES)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Now that Bob Menendez...
-Another bute.
-MATT: Oh, boy.
-The guy with the gold bars
in his jacket.
-MATT: You know, I mean just--
This-- this-- this-- He was--
Ju-- this FARA charge,
-this foreign agent
registry charge.
-BILL: Yeah, it's a--
-Will he be f-- Yeah.
-I mean, which is an addition
to the bribery
which is pretty amazing.
Because, I mean,
working in Washington
and James probably knows
it's like to run a foul
-of FARA, the Foreign Agents...
-JAMES: Yeah.
...Registration Act,
you have to want to get caught.
These are so loosely enforced
and I just--
As with this,
as with the bribery charge,
when you read
what he actually did,
it's like Menendez
was like, "Challenge accepted."
(JAMES CHUCKLING)
-I, you know...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(CHUCKLING)
-"I am going to be
so blatant and sloppy."
(AUDIENCE CHEERS, APPLAUDS)
Okay, uh, well, the US
right to freeze access
to the six billion in funds
it transferred to Iran
as part of the prisoner deal
we negotiated--
-Oh, was the US right
to freeze that...
-JAMES: Yes
...we negotiated last month?
Okay, so if people don't know,
we wanted to get
-how many people back? Five?
-Five. We got them back.
We got them back
and we paid
-six billion dollars.
-JAMES: Six billion dollars.
We didn't pay it. It was money
that...
-BILL: Yes. Okay.
-JAMES: ...was owed to Ukraine--
MATT: No, it was Iran's money...
-...from oil
that had been sanctioned.
-Sold to South Korea.
Okay, but we made the deal,
we got the people back,
and now we're not giving them
the money.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
I mean, I'm not-- (LAUGHS)
I'm not... (CHUCKLES) ...taking
Iran's side in this,
but you know
we did have a deal.
I mean, we have a history
of breaking deals with Iran,
-unfortunately, but...
-BILL: With everybody.
The charge was made that,
you know, I think, Tim Scott
and others made this
completely demagogic,
you know, false claim
that, you know,
this money helped to fund
the attacks we saw last weekend
which is absurd
for a number of reasons,
not least of which is this--
None of this money
had been dispersed yet.
They haven't seen
a cent of it.
But there's a larger point
that we should have maintained
the pressure campaign
on Iran that
the Trump Administration started
and that, that was rolled
and dialed back
by the Biden Administration
and it has allowed--
That's really not true.
They've kept in
-almost every element...
-They have not maintained--
...of the Trump--
No, they absolutely have.
What we should have done
is cap the deal Obama made.
MATT: Right, that's exactly
what we should have done.
-No?
-No way.
-No.
This regime--
This Iranian regime,
how can you make
a deal with this Iranian regime?
Well, if you have a deal
that keeps them away
from a nuclear weapon,
make that fucking deal.
-And they did. And they--
Obama made that deal.
-MATT: That's right.
I mean, it was like this...
With a sunset clause
of 12 years, okay?
So, it was just postponed
by 12 years,
the date that they got
a nuclear weapon.
Okay, well, nothing--
No deal is perfect.
Isn't that what we're saying
about the Palestinians
-with the West Bank?
-MATT: That's right.
They could have had
their own country many times.
Not many times, but a few times.
Certainly in 2000.
Then again, there are deals
that Israel could have taken
and didn't.
Right. They could have had
97 percent of the West Bank
but they-- It was not perfect,
as no deal is,
because Israel was not
about to give it to them
just say, "Oh, you know what,
do your thing."
They were like, "Yes,
we have to keep an eye on you,
for very good reason."
But over time
if they had taken that deal,
where would the world be today
in 2023, if there had been a--
if Arafat had taken that deal
and in 2000 there was state?
Yes, then you show Israel
we're not out to get--
MATT: Yeah, somehow we got back
to Israel-Palestine, uh,
-from Iran.
-BILL: Okay.
But I'll just get back
to the Iran deal for a minute.
I think, important to understand
about this six billion
is that it was going to be--
is handled and held by Qatar
and was going to be spent
by Qatar
on specific humanitarian items.
-BILL: So they say.
-So, it's not like
we're giving Iran--
Under strict monitoring.
-JAMES: But money is fungible.
-BILL: Yes.
Money is fungible,
and money that can go
to paying for humanitarian goods
can be also used on
-various purposes.
-No, but it's not as if--
And listen, as they say,
the military eats first, right?
So, Iran has not been--
even though they are under
some of the heaviest sanction
in the world,
they still have not been,
you know,
they still have money to spend
on their military
and all their, you know,
their nefarious activities.
This is just giving money
to actually help their people.
Again,
not defending this regime.
No one should.
But, I think, let's understand
the nature of this six billion
-and what it was
gonna be used for.
-BILL: I got one last question.
I've been hearing a lot
this week that Nikki Haley
is really kicking ass,
that she's rising up
in the Republican Party.
There she is. And, uh, I see
George Will's column says,
uh, Tim Scott should bow out
of the race, throw his support
to Nikki Haley,
encourage everybody else
in the race
to do the same thing.
That this
is the viable alternative
-to Donald Trump. And-- and...
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
...and if we just had a race...
If we just had a republican race
with just two people
and Nikki Haley
was the alternative,
it's possible that she would
take it from Trump.
There's a chance.
And I thought she did great
in the first debate,
not as good
in the second debate.
But, look, he has
over 50 percent
-Trump does.
-BILL: Now.
-Now, and yeah--
-BILL: But if it was just
two people-- So there's--
Perhaps. She would have
a fighting chance, and yes,
I would absolutely--
that all the other
Republicans running now,
need to do their patriotic duty
and do what they didn't do
the last time
-and they need to rally behind
one anti-Trump alternative.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-BILL: And she--
-Yeah, I don't know, we'll see--
You know, if you remember,
you know, Trump has not really
taken her on yet. He's waiting.
If you remember from,
you know, Lord of the Rings,
-you know, the Eye of Sauron...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-MATT: Once the...
-I-- I don't.
...Once the eye of Trump
turns to Nikki Haley,
-with all its withering power--
(LAUGHS)
-I don't know movies like that.
All right, thank you, guys.
I appreciate it.
Thank you, everyone.